bonjour à tous cet après midi les
sénateurs examinent une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle du groupe radical
un texte qui vise à renforcer la
fonction de représentation des
collectivités territoriales par le sénat
constitutionnellement le sénat
représente les collectivités
territoriales mais aussi par la
constitution
le sénat n'a jamais le dernier mot sur
l'assemblée nationale en cas de
désaccord des deux assemblées sur un
texte de loi et donc même sur un texte
lié aux collectivités territoriales le
sénat peut voir sa volonté outre passer
par celle de l'assemblée
cette proposition de loi du groupe
radical vise à créer une exception faire
en sorte que tout texte lié à
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales échappent à cette
procédure
c'est en quelque sorte une réponse du
sénat à l'assemblée on se rappelle que
lors de la réforme des collectivités
territoriales l'assemblée est revenue à
plusieurs reprises sur les modifications
apportées par le sénat
suscitant beaucoup de colère parmi les
sénateurs tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle travail séance l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
tendant à renforcer la fonction de
représentation par le sénat dès
collecter territoriale de la république
présentée par monsieur yvon collin et
les membres du groupe fdsea dans la
discussion générale
la parole est au président collin auteur
de la proposition de loi mais non loin
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues pas très nombreux
bien qu'il s'agisse portant de renforcer
les droits
le pouvoir du sénat et son rôle en
matière de défense de nos collectivités
locales d'un monsieur sénateurs mais
chez collègues avaient le soutien de
l'ensemble des membres de mon groupe
le dire déçu par delà des clivages
politiques qui le composent j'ai
l'honneur de soumettre aujourd'hui à
l'examen des membres de la haute
assemblée une proposition de loi du rdse
qui a l'ambition de combler un silence
regrettable notre constitution et par là
même de renforcer le sénat dans sa
fonction constitutionnel de
représentation des collectivités
territoriales en effet mes chers
collègues nous vous proposons par ce
texte d'aller au bout de la logique sous
tendu par les articles 24 et 39 du texte
constitutionnel
en soustrayant les projets et
propositions de loi ayant pour principal
objet l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales à la procédure offrant le
cas échéant à l'assemblée nationale la
possibilité de statuer définitivement
sans l'accord du sénat à vous proposant
cette modification de l'article 45 de la
constitution
nous sommes bien conscients de soulever
un débat qui va au delà d'un simple
ajustement technique de la procédure
parlementaire
en tout état de cause c'est bien toute
la question cruciale de la place du
sénat dans nos institutions est celle du
respect qui doit être due à sa fonction
de représentation des collectivités
locales qui est posée à l'évidence
l'actualité de ces derniers mois a
malheureusement démontré qu'en dépit des
prérogatives qui lui sont
constitutionnellement réservés notre
assemblée a fait l'objet d'un mettrie
souveraine qui a affecté l'ensemble de
ses membres et par delà tous les grands
électeurs que nous sommes dont nous
sommes ici l'émanation et la
représentation
c'est donc bien l'actualité en l'espèce
les conditions d'examen et d'adoption du
projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales qui vont
expirer ce texte
le texte cette proposition de loi qu'il
a d'autres objectifs que de garantir
constitutionnellement et formellement
oscillant toute la place qui doit être
la sienne car mes chers collègues que
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
l'article 24 de la constitution dispose
que le sénat assure la représentation
des collectivités territoriales de la
république
cela signifie que dans notre république
unitaire indivisible la représentation
des collectivités par le sénat et bien
sûr une modalités techniques de la
représentation du peuple souverain qui
s'exprime par le suffrage universel
direct mais cela exprime également
l'idée d'une représentation de la nation
dans les corps intermédiaires
territoriaux comme le concevait
d'ailleurs les rédacteurs de la
constitution
en clair la représentation par le sénat
et politique est aussi légitime quoique
différente que celle de l'assemblée
nationale et à l'aune de cette idée qu
après de longs débats qui ont été
instituées en 2003 au profit du sénat
est à l'initiative de notre collègue
jean pierre raffarin alors premier
ministre
une priorité d'examen des projets de loi
ayant pour principal objet
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales
cette heureuse modification du deuxième
alinéa de l'article 30 de la
constitution ainsi en quelque sorte
institutionnalisée une pratique presque
systématique les gouvernements
successifs elle est également venu
prolonger la logique qui sous tendait
depuis 1958 la fonction représentative
du sénat en formalisant cette priorité
qui découlent du rôle qui lui est dévolu
de chambre de la diversité de nos
territoires
dans notre esprit le sénat n'est pas
doté d'une supériorité irréfragable sur
l'assemblée nationale en matière de
collectivités territoriales
de la même façon qui n'est pas le porte
voix unique les préoccupations des élus
locaux nous ne constituons pas le
réceptacle d'intérêts purement
catégorielles nous sommes cependant en
première ligne sur ce front et avec le
texte que vous ne propose que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui
nous ne mettons pas le sénat au dessus
de l'assemblée nationale en matière de
collectivités territoriales nous mettons
simplement en cette matière les deux
assemblées parlementaires au même niveau
une constitution c'est un esprit des
institutions une pratique déclaré le
général de gaulle en 1964 précisément la
pratique de nos institutions
or est en toute logique dû conduire
assurer le respect de cette prérogative
consacré par le constituant et lors de
l'examen de la désastreuse réforme des
collectivités territoriales nous avons
connu par la pratique justement la
démonstration malheureuse du
détournement non seulement de l'esprit
mais aussi de la lettre de la
constitution ça refaire l'historique de
ce texte il est évident qu'il était dès
l'origine mal conçus dans sa méthode
même méthode qui était selon moi à
l'opposé du consensus et de la
négociation nécessaire sur un sujet qui
dépasse les appartenances partisanes
pourtant les conclusions de la mission
désormais célèbre la mission melon qui
associé toutes les sensibilités du sénat
ont été superbement ignoré de faire une
réforme aussi majeur pour l'avenir de
nos collectivités et à travers elle pour
celui de nos concitoyennes n'aurait
jamais dû faire l'objet de passage en
force auquel nous avons assisté avec
consternation la navette entre les deux
chambres
vite aussi se mettre en avant
détournement de l'esprit de la
constitution le gouvernement avait
initialement annoncé que les
dispositions relatives au mode de
scrutin du conseiller territorial et aux
compétences des collectivités
territoriales forêt le joug le ferez
l'objet de projets de loi distincts tout
tout débat sur ce sujet nous fut
d'ailleurs presque interdite dans cet
hémicycle en première lecture
en dix ans nous verrons plus tard mais
cet engagement de dupes ne l'empêcha pas
d'introduire lui-même ou par l'entremise
de là
mission ces dispositions par voie
d'amendements à l'assemblée nationale au
mépris de la parole donnée préalablement
devant le sénat comme le démontre a
brillamment notre excellent collègue
jacques mézard en défendant la motion
déception ni recevabilité en deuxième
lecture la procédure législative avait
été dénaturé en vidant de son contenu
l'article 39 de la constitution qui
accorde la priorité d'examen du sénat
l'application au droit d'amendement de
la règle de l'entonnoir bien connu
dégagée par le conseil constitutionnel a
en réalité été menée de telle sorte que
la procédure législative a été dénaturé
voire même vicié au regard de l'atteinte
portée au principe de clarté et de
sincérité des débats en étant contraints
d'accepter de se prononcer dans ces
conditions je le dis solennellement le
sénat a été humilié mes chers collègues
les deux chambres du parlement ont
exprimé à l'occasion de l'examen de ce
texte de profonds désaccords sur des
points majeurs touchant l'organisation
et le fonctionnement de nos
collectivités
l'esprit de notre constitution mais
aussi celui de nos institutions
toman que la parole du sénat soit écouté
entendu et surtout respecter au terme de
ces deux lectures dans chacune de nos
deux assemblées il n'était tout
simplement pas possible n'était
simplement pas possible que soit
convoqué le cmpe et sauf a préféré se
moquer du sénat c'est d'ailleurs en ce
sens que j'avais écrit au premier
ministre le 17 septembre dernier pour
son âne helmand lui demander de ne pas
convoquer le cnt ce qui peut relever ne
peut relever que de lui et d'organiser
une troisième lecture
dans chacune des deux assemblées compte
tenu du profonds désaccords qui
persistent et j'en avais également
d'ailleurs avisé les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
et je sais que bon nombre de nos
collègues sur l'ensemble des bancs de
cet hémicycle partager la position que
j'ai défendue il était manifeste que
faire le choix d'une cmp reviendrait
pour le gouvernement
à opérer un véritable coup de force à
l'égard du sénat et des collectivités
territoriales
tous les sénateurs à tous les stades de
la procédure aurait dû pouvoir se
prononcer et pas seulement une poignée
d'entre eux savamment choisis savamment
choisis pour composer la cmp
en d'autres termes c'est un véritable
chantage politique qui s'est ainsi
l'exercice sur le sénat chantage
alimentée par la menace à peine voilée
de donner le dernier mot à l'assemblée
nationale en contradiction avec l'esprit
même de la constitution
lors de l'examen de la grande loi de
on s'en souvient tous vents nombreux
sont ceux qui se souviennent
répartissant les compétences entre les
communes les départements et des régions
et l'état texte à leur portée par une
majorité de gauche
le gouvernement de l'époque avait su
afficher tout son respect pour le sénat
à majorité de droite
la haute assemblée avait eu tout
l'espace nécessaire pour s'exprimer
parmi les apports majeurs de cette loi
certaines étaient d'initiative
sénatoriales telle interdiction de la
tutelle d'une collectivité sur une autre
fondateur important c'est dire si un
sujet aussi primordial permet toujours
de réunir les bonnes volontés
lorsque le dialogue mais aussi
l'écoutent sont appliquées comme méthode
de travail
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
notre proposition de loi n'a d'autre
objet que d'empêcher pour l'avenir que
se reproduise une situation aussi
intolérable que celle que nous venons de
connaître
et que l'on ne puisse plus aussi
aisément porter atteinte à la dignité de
notre haute assemblée notre texte ne
fait finalement calé au bout de la
logique de la révision constitutionnelle
de 2003 de surcroît un tel dispositif
plaçant l'assemblée et le sénat sur un
pied d'égalité existe déjà
s'agissant des lois organiques qui
concerne le sénat et les projets ou
propositions de loi de révision de la
constitution nous l'entendons donc pas
ouvrir une brèche dans ce bel
ordonnancement constitutionnel
mais mettre fin à une double incohérence
juridique et politique
nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas la primeur
de cette idée et je me réjouis qu'elle
fut et qu'elle puisse encore je l'espère
être partagés sur d'autres banques
nos collègues christian poncelet alors
président de notre assemblée jean pierre
raffarin et jean pierre fourcade de
bonnes références avait déposée en 2000
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
relative à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et à ses
applications financières et fiscales
son article 3 ce proposé d'insérer
nouvel article 72 3 de la constitution
qui aurait disposé que les projets ou
propositions de loi relatives à
l'administration des collectivités
territoriales doivent être voté dans les
mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
l'objectif de nos collègues alors été
selon le res poser des motifs de tirer
les coaches site bien sûr de tirer les
conséquences de la responsabilité
spécifique du sénat de garam de la libre
administration des collectivités locales
en confortant son rôle
une idée à laquelle nous souscrivons
pleinement aujourd'hui lors des débats
sur ce texte
notre collègue le président christian
poncelet soutiennent avec la force de
conviction qu'on lui connaît quand rôle
accru devait être nécessairement être
accordée au sénat car je le cite je cite
encore une telle extension de ses
compétences qui découle tout
naturellement de sa vocation
constitutionnel serait le gage d'une
bonne législation au service de cette
république territoriales dont
l'avènement doit être et sera disait-il
le catalyseur d'une france que nous
voulons moderne dynamique et solide et
al
je partage pleinement cette définition
de la décentralisation et elle est
d'ailleurs la position que les membres
du rdse ont constamment défendu tout au
long de l'examen de la réforme
territoriale dans les débats de 2000
toujours notre collège jean pierre
raffarin
défendez l'idée que la légitimité du
sénat je cite pour être renforcé a
besoin d'une puissance
strativa le même renforcé c'est
précisément l'idée que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui doté notre céda
notre sénat dans le seul cadre qu'offre
la constitution des outils lui
permettant de ne pas laisser sa volonté
souveraine de pouvoir constituer être
annihilée par d'autres pouvoirs
constitués
certes le sénat adopte a finalement 2000
une rédaction différentes qui prévoyait
qu'une loi organique fixera
l'organisation et les compétences et des
collectivités territoriales
sauf sauf en matière de ressources pour
ne pas empiéter sur la spécificité des
lois de finances en cas de désaccord
entre les deux assemblées le dernier mot
serait revenu à l'assemblée nationale
mais à la majorité absolue de ses
membres
comme pour toute loi organique à
l'exception de celle relative au sénat
c'est sur ces recommandations du
rapporteur de l'époque celui là même
jallet m'apprêtais à dire qui est assise
à la même place que cette je passe à
patrice gélard qui était à la même place
que la rédaction fut retenue monsieur le
rapporteur de l'époque
vous ne me ferez pas vous estimé à
l'époque que l'adoption en termes
identiques par et de chameau serait de
nature à permettre et je cite le
rapporteur de l'époque au sénat de jouer
tout son rôle pour prévenir l'adoption
de dispositions de nature à remettre en
cause les principes essentiels de la
décentralisation
laissez moi vous dire que vous aviez
raison monsieur le rapporteur gélard
avec dix ans d'avancé puisque nous
venons d'avoir la démonstration
malheureuse que le sénat malgré ses
efforts redoublés n'a pu effectivement
bêcher l'adoption de lois qui supporte
une régression majeure à la
décentralisation monsieur le rapporteur
généralement lu avec attention votre
rapport sur notre texte
j'ai été heureux de constater que vous
partagiez toujours je m'en réjouis
notre volonté de défendre le rôle
éminent du sénat dans le domaine des
collectivités territoires votre opinion
a même évolué depuis 2000 puisque vous
estimez pas injustifiée l'exigence d'un
accord des deux assemblées pour
l'addiction le texte concernant à titre
principal l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales mais ensuite
bien la suite n'a hélas laisser perplexe
et pour tout dire elle m'a un peu déçu
je ne peux résolument pas partager votre
analyse des raisons qui justifieraient
le renvoi en commission de notre
proposition de loi il est vrai qu'une
révision constitutionnelle d'origine
parlementaire nécessiterait une
approbation par voie référendaire
il est sans doute tout aussi vrai que
convoqué le peuple français sur ce sujet
ne déchaîne pas a priori de grandes
passions mais encore que rien n'est si
sûr car nos compatriotes comprendre
aisément les enjeux véritables cette
réforme dont ils seraient les premiers
bénéficiaires mais permettez moi de vous
dire que votre argumentation et surtout
très commode pour évacuer le fond de la
question qui est posée à chacun de nos
collègues et pourtant vous avez aussi
convenu en présentant votre rapport que
les réputés n'avait pas suffisamment
tenu compte des positions du sénat dans
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales sur tous ces points
notre argumentation finalement monsieur
le rapporteur vous êtes d'accord avec
nous pourquoi alors évacué ce texte par
un soupirail conserver ce texte en
réserve pour le rattacher un très
hypothétique futur projet de loi
constitutionnelle est au mieux
permettez-moi leur dire un manque
d'audace au pire une façon dérober de ne
pas réparer l'humiliation porté au sénat
vous raisonnez par simple utilitarisme
en termes de chance et de succès et de
cette façon vous pouvez tout justifier
tout et son contraire
nous raisonnons quand annonces sur des
principes et les principes que nous
défendons aujourd'hui revêtent une
particulière gravité
en allant au bout de la logique
institutionnelle initié en 2003 à noter
le dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale
en matière de collectivités
territoriales le sénat enverrait un
message politique très claire à la fois
au gouvernement monsieur ministre et à
nos collègues députés celui du refus du
rabaissement mes chers collègues la
constitution n'a pas fait du sénat de
chameau consulter
yves comme du temps du conseil de la
république loin de nous l'idée de
déclencher le matin et institutionnels
mais force est de constater que les
autres détenteurs de l'initiative
législative nous ont jusqu'à présent
guère épargné sur le sujet des
collectivités comment expliquer demain
aux élus locaux de ce pays que les
sénateurs qui élisent pour entre entre
autres les représenter qu'ils élisent
pour les représenter sont en train de
perdre leur pouvoir d'influer sur le
statut et les compétences de leurs
collectivités
quelle cohérence y aurait-il à donner au
sénat une peau une priorité d'examen des
projets de loi ayant pour principal
objet l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales
si son vote n'a guère d'importance à
quoi bon avoir le premier mot depuis la
révision constitutionnelle de 2003
si l'assemblée nationale peut avoir le
dernier mot mes chers collègues vous
l'avez compris notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle est d'abord un message
fort destiné à réparer l'humiliation
subie par le sénat dans des conditions
navrante qui ont guidé l'examen du
projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales mais notre
texte n'est pas que cela puisqu'il
répond un véritable silence du texte
constitutionnel
ah le con blanc de façon cohérente mais
aussi monsieur le rapporteur mesure et
il en a aujourd'hui de l'honneur du
sénat de la république mais aussi de
celui de tous ses membres qui concourent
à l'expression de la volonté générale
pour toutes ces raisons ce le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans l'intérêt du sénat et des
collectivités territoriales de ce pays
je vous invite mes chers collègues à
faire preuve de responsabilité en
repoussant d'une part la motion de
renvoi en commission et d'autre part en
adoptant cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle du groupe rdse et je
vous remercie de votre grande attente
merci cher président colin pour votre
intervention en psy brillante et
maintenant je vais donner la parole aux
présidents y est qui va suppléer au pied
levé le rapporteur de la commission des
lois
retenu par la neige dans son département
d'un autre collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
tendant à renforcer la fonction de
représentation par le sénat les
collectivités territoriales de la
république présentées avec combien de
brio par le président colin ou ses
collègues hier des sultans à compléter
l'article 45 de la constitution pour
écarter les dispositions tendant à
donner le dernier mot à l'assemblée
nationale lorsque le parlement se
prononce sur des projets de loi ou les
propositions de loi ayant pour principal
objet l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales la disposition proposée a
donc pour objet d'interdire que des
modifications importantes touchant
collectivités territoriales soit adoptée
sans tenir compte des positions du sénat
voire contre son avis elle repose sur
trois arguments constitutionnels et une
considération de circonstance d'abord
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président cola aux termes de l'article
24 de la constitution le sénat assure la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
ensuite depuis la loi constitutionnelle
du 28 mars 2003 relative à
l'organisation décentralisée de la
république
l'article 39 de la constitution prévoit
que les projets de loi ayant pour
principal objet l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales sont soumis
en premier lieu au sénat
et enfin en outre d'ores et déjà
l'accord du sénat est requis pour les
lois organiques qui le concerne en vertu
de l'article 36 de la constitution ainsi
que pour les projets ou propositions de
loi constitutionnelle c'est l'article 89
il faut quand même rappeler qu'on est à
égalité dans ce domaine bien que le
conseil constitutionnel en ce qui
concerne les lois organiques concernant
le sénat à prof a sérieusement restreint
le champ de cet article alors vous avez
bien entendu rap et monsieur le
président colin l'examen du projet de
loi de réforme des collectivités
territoriales adoptée par le parlement
17 novembre 2010 et qui aurait selon les
auteurs de la proposition de loi
démontré que les profonds désaccords
peuvent exister entre le sénat
l'assemblée sur des points majeurs
les dispositions particulièrement
importants touchant à l'organisation et
au fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales en toute logique indiqué
vous un thème comme celui ci ayant un
tel impact sur l'organisation
territoriale de la république et au delà
sur la vie tous les concitoyens doit
recueillir l'assentiment du sénat notre
commission des lois partage la volonté
exprimée par monsieur cola de défend de
rôle imminent du sénat dans le domaine
des collectivités territoriales c'est
pas forcément le cas de tous tout même
au sénat un bon voilà et vous n'êtes pas
avec continuité monsieur le président
colin est historiquement avec continuité
votre groupe a toujours défendu le rôle
du sénat
voilà nos si elle n'estime pas à
justifier exigeant un accord des deux
assemblées pour l'adoption de tests
concernaient à titre principal
organisation des collectivités
territoriales
cependant c'est là où on vous déçoit
remet enfin elle considère que la
procédure référendaire qu'un pic
nécessairement une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et pas la plus adaptée
depuis 1958 les deux tiers des 3200
trois lois qui ont été adoptées dans le
cadre de la navette sans qu'il soit
nécessaire provoqué l'intervention d'une
commission paritaire
22 17 % des textes ont été votés à
l'issue d'une cmp et 11,11 % donné lieu
au dernier mot à l'assemblée
ces divergences certain nombre limité
pour néanmoins sur des textes est plus
sensible et en particulier sur ses
intérêts sans l'état les collectivités
territoriales
néanmoins tel n'est toujours pas le cas
vous avez cité un certain d'exemple
parmi lés premières lois de
décentralisation la loi du 7 janvier 83
relative à la répartition des
compétences entre communes les
départements les régions et d'état a été
adoptée sur la base du texte et à l'est
par la cmp et vous avez rappelé aussi
que parmi les apports du sénat il
convient de signaler l'interdiction date
une telle une collectivité sur une autre
certaines collectivités ferait bien de
s'en souvenir
d'ailleurs
ou encore l'affirmation du principe d'un
transfert par blocs de compétences
oui qu'on parlait déjà des compétences à
l'époque de même la loi relative au
renforcement et à la simplification de
la coopération intercommunale du 12
juillet 99 a donné lieu à un accord à
l'issue d'une cmp ainsi sur la base de
l'expérience et des expertises acquises
dans le domaine des collectivités
territoriales les positions défendues
par le sénat sont susceptibles
d'emporter l'adhésion malgré les
clivages politiques
plusieurs principes fondamentaux promu
par le sénat a d'ailleurs été inscrits
dans le titre 12 de la constitution à la
faveur de la révision du 18 mars 2003 et
encadre désormais l'évolution du droit
dans le domaine des collectivités
territoriales ainsi la mission de
représentation des collectivités
territoriales assigne au sénat par ati
24 de la constitution ne s'arrête pas au
seul mode d'élection des sénateurs mais
il s'exprime aussi dans l'influencé
qu'ils exercent sur la législation
intéressant ces questions le principe
d'un accord entre les deux assemblées
pour l'adoption de tête de tel texte
permettrait bien entendu de garantir ce
rôle
cette évolution de notre droit
constitutionnel pourrait être donc
d'autant mieux accepté que la notion
d'organisation des collectivités
territoriales a été précisé est
circonscrit à l'occasion des débats
parlementaires concernant d'adoua du
constitutionnel du 28 mars 2003 relative
à l'organisation des centrales d'acide
décentralisée de la république
cette notion recouvre le choix du nom
des collectivités territoriales la
détermination des règles relatives à
leurs organes et à leurs actes ainsi que
la fixation de limites territoriales
elle comprend pas monsieur le président
en revanche des modes de scrutin
oui
en outre l'exigence d'un accord entre
les deux assemblées pourrait constituer
le prolongement de la priorité d'examen
reconnu au sénat par la révision du 28
mars 2003 d'ailleurs le projet de loi 61
concernant les collectivités
territoriales avait été déposée au sénat
comme le rappelait on déposer ensuite
c'est l'assemblée qui en fait ce qu'elle
veut c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est
comme ça au demeurant la cedh a déjà
envisagé à l'occasion de cette révision
une modification eu des dispositions de
l'article 45 tout en y renonçant par
souci de compromis
ainsi votre commission des lois avait
proposé que la loi organique relative
aux ressources financières des
collectivités territoriales soit votée
dans les mêmes termes par les deux
assemblées
elle reprenait une disposition de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
présenté par le président christian
poncelet pur ses collègues relative à la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales selon laquelle l'assemblée
nationale n'aurait pu avoir le dernier
mot
pour l'adoption des lois organiques hui
sans la liste l'assiette et les
modalités de recouvrement des recettes
fiscales propres des collectivités
territoriales serait-il rêve pour le
sénat cependant notre commission estime
qu'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle des paf le vecteur le
plus adapté pour cette réforme
en effet elle implique aux termes de
l'article 89 de la constitution une
adoption par voie référendaire
seul un projet de loi constitutionnelle
peut être soumis au parlement convoqué
en congrès pour un sujet comme celui-ci
de nature plus institutionnel que
politique se prête moins à une
consultation populaire qu'est l'adoption
par le congrès selon une procédure
d'ailleurs retenu pour la totale
quasi-totalité des réformes
constitutionnelles conduite sur la base
de l'article 89
bien entendu à l'exception de
l'introduction du quinquennat par la loi
constitutionnelle du 2 octobre de ville
le président colin moi je voudrais
ajouter quelque chose il faut rappeler
que certes le sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales c'est sa
fonction constitutionnel mais ce n'est
pas parce que nous sommes élus au
scrutin au suffrage indirect que nous ne
sommes pas une assemblée parlementaire
de plein exercice et que certains qui
voudraient nous cantonner à nous non
je voudrais oui mais je il faut le
rappeler de temps en temps qui voudrait
nous cantonner à simplement nous occuper
des pannes des collectivités
territoriales non non non non mais je le
dis aussi parce que ça pourrait la
tentation bas occupez vous des
collectivités territoriales ne vous
occupez pas du reste nous sommes des
législateurs de plein exercice
nous pesons dans tous les débats de
société autant que l'assemblée bien
entendu faut bien trouver un moment où
il ya le dernier mot pour que les lois
soient votées mais je puis vous assurer
que le sénat doit doit continuer à
garder sa spécificité sur un certain
nombre de sujets et je pense qu'en 2d
dans un débat compliqué à l'heure
actuelle parce que c'est un manque de
repères une crise etc
je pense que la valeur ajoutée du sénat
notamment dans le domaine des libertés
publiques n'est pas à négliger
c'est le petit commentaire que je
voulais ajouter monsieur le président
colin au bénéfice de ses observations
votre commission pour ne pas insulter
l'avenir
pour ne pas insulter l'avenir a décidé
de ne pas établir de theix et de ne pas
demander le rejet du texte mais
d'adopter une motion tendant au renvoi
en commission de la présente proposition
de loi dans la tente de son examen
éventuelle lors d'une prochaine révision
constitutionnelle les contrairement à ce
que certains disent le renvoi en
commission pour la commission des lois
n'est pas forcément un enterrement de
première classe
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président à porter la parole est
maintenant à monsieur philippe richert
ministre en charge des collectivités d
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le président collin
auteur de la proposition de loi que nous
examinons mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs proposition de loi
constitutionnelle que vous présentez le
président colin vise à modifier
l'article 45 de la constitution afin que
la procédure du dernier mot ne puisse
plus appliqués aux propositions et
projets de loi ayant pour objet
principal l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales je voudrais
tout d'abord rappelé à titre liminaire
le cadre général de cette procédure du
dernier mot l'article 45 de la
constitution prévoit que dans le cas où
les deux assemblées ne sont pas parvenus
à un accord sur la proposition à nos
projets de loi à l'issue de la
commission mixte paritaire le
gouvernement peut demander à l'assemblée
nationale de statuer définitivement sur
le texte faculté la procédure est la
suivante une ultime navette est alors
organisée en vue d'une nouvelle lecture
par l'assemblée puis par le sénat
et enfin seulement le dernier mot et
donner le cas échéant l'assemblée
nationale le constituant a souhaité
donner le dernier mot à l'assemblée
nationale élue au suffrage universel
direct par le peuple
allan théo d'abord de développer en
trois parties m'ont exposé tout d'abord
la pratique du dermau et navettes
parlementaires des moyens de lever les
esses désaccord entre les assemblées la
philosophie
l'article 45 de la constitution et la
pratique relève que l' usage du dernier
mort est et doit rester limitée le
principe est celui fixé au premier
alinéa de l'article 45 la loi résulte de
l'adoption par les deux chambres d'un
texte identique
la quasi-totalité des lois et adopté
conforme par les deux assemblées
président y est en parlais tout à
l'heure sans qu'il soit besoin de
recourir au dernier mot la procédure est
tout entière construite pour faire
converger les positions des deux
assemblées du parlement le plus souvent
d'ailleurs
l'accord intervient entre les chambres
sans qu'il soit même besoin de convoquer
une c'est un peu une cmp
depuis le 1er octobre 2007 sur les 316
voix adopté 65 seulement aux nécessités
la réunion d'une commission mixte
les chiffres de l'activité parlementaire
montre également que nombre de textes
votés par le sénat sont adoptées par
l'assemblée nationale sans modification
pas moins de quarante cinq textes sur la
même période sur les 316 adopté
l'on était adopté tel que voté par le
sénat le recours au dernier alinéa de
l'article 2 45 et exceptionnel donc le
dernier mot a été donné plusieurs fois
l'assemblée nationale entre 2001 et 2002
loi de modernisation sociale loi sur la
corse loi sur les professions de santé
depuis la procédure a été déclenchée une
seule fois une seule fois au printemps
2010 pour une disposition de loi
organique relative à l'application de
l'année 1 5 de l'article 13 de la
constitution
excepté donc ce dernier cas l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat se sont accordés
la navette de l'occasion commission
ainsi qu'aux deux assemblées
parlementaires d'exprimer mais aussi de
rapprocher progressivement leur point de
vue on l'a vu sur la loi sur la réforme
des collectivités à laquelle nous
faisait référence
entre la loi déposé par le gouvernement
la loi qui est sorti du vote des
assemblées on a vu qu'à chaque fois que
la loi est passée devant ligne ou
l'autre des assemblées ont des
modifications substantielles sont
intervenus donc c'est quelque chose qui
est utile bien sûr pour permettre
d'améliorer à la fois les lois mais
aussi de rapprocher les positions entre
les deux assemblées avec la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 le travail en
commissions y contribue fortement
deuxième logique que je voudrais
expliquer c'est la logique
institutionnelle du bicaméralisme la
faculté laissée à l'assemblée nationale
en cas de blocage persistant de trancher
ultime en est un élément de l' équilibre
de la procédure législative de notre
démocratie
cette logique a d'ailleurs été préservé
par la réforme constitutionnelle de
juillet 2008 au cours de laquelle aucun
de vous aucun de vous ne souhaitez sa
remise en cause
il est vrai que la constitution a confié
à votre assemblée qu était l époque
aussi la mienne une très haute et
d'examen pour les textes pourtant à
titre principal sur l'organisation des
collectivités locales le constituant
consacre ainsi une fonction de
représentation de ces collectivités et
lui donne toute sa portée cela vous
confère un rôle déterminant de la
définition de législation dans cette
matière lors de l'examen de la réforme
des collectivités territoriales vous
avez imprimer votre marque sur de
nombreux sujets comme l'achèvement de la
carte intercommunale le mode élections
des délégués communautaires les
métropoles et d'autre au plus fort de la
crise parce qu'il y avait crise
vous avez choisi de mettre en place le
remboursement anticipé du fonds de
compensation de la tva qui a permis de
soutenir l'économie locale j'ajoute que
depuis octobre 2007
pas moins de quarante cinq textes ont
été adoptés conforme par l'assemblée
nationale sur la base de la rédaction
issue du sénat je le disais tout à
l'heure
faut-il se privait d'une dispositions
qui permettent dans des cas somme toute
exceptionnelle de dépasser les clivages
et d'empêcher la paralysie
institutionnelle au at il fallu en 1982
se priver de la grande loi de
décentralisation
c'est ça la question le constituant a
déjà prévu deux exceptions la procédure
du dernier mot de l'article 45 et ses
exceptions sont strictement limitées
ainsi la loi organique relative au sénat
doivent impérativement être voté dans
les mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
l'on comprend aisément quand votre
conformes soit requis pour les textes
qui concerne l'organisation et la
constitution composition de votre
assemblée
il en de même pour les révisions
constitutionnelles à portée de cet ex
justifient qu'il soit adopté dans les
mêmes termes par les deux assemblées le
troisième paragraphe que je voudrais
développer
c'est la question de l' équilibre du
bicamérisme en réalité par cette
modification monsieur le président vous
tondez à rapprocher notre façon de
légiférer que la pratique qui est en
oeuvre dans plusieurs pays d'europe
je prends l'exemple l'allemagne dans ce
pays le bundesrat qui représente les
länder et les länder ils sont
représentés d'office par les ministres
présidents et un certain nombre de
membres des länder en fonction de la
taille de l'importance de ceux-ci
oui dans notre manioc le bundesrat qui
représente les länder à la possibilité
pour les textes qui concernent les
collectivités la fiscalité les finances
de refuser la mise en oeuvre des textes
votés par le bundestag
donc les députés dès lors que le
bundestag ne donne pas son accord
en fait le dernier mot ne revient pas au
bundestag sur tous ces domaines
notamment celui que vous préconisez à
savoir celui qui concerne les
collectivités il y as en allemagne ce
qu'il faut comprendre un autre équilibre
c'est qu'effectivement le bundesrat a la
possibilité d'avoir le dernier mot en
même temps que l'assemblée nationale
mais en contrepartie c'est ce
qu'explique et jean jacques hyest
c'est que le bundesrat n'a pas la
possibilité de s'exprimer sur l'ensemble
des textes de loi ne vienne au bundesrat
que les textes pour lesquels il a
compétence et pour lesquels
effectivement il a de ce coup le dernier
mot ce qui fait que les lois disons
ordinaire qui concerne la vie
communautaire la vie de la communauté
nationale ne sont pas soumis au
bundesrat
la question c'est donc globalement tout
l'équilibré qu'il s'agit de trouver
entre d'un côté l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat le bundestag et le bundesrat
nous avons choisi chez nous d'avoir un
équilibre qui fait que le sénat reçoit
l'ensemble des textes la même compétence
que l'assemblée nationale mais il faut
laisser quelqu'un pouvoir décider en
dernier ressort
en allemagne ils ont fait le choix
inverse est de dire que les deux sur un
nombre de points limités ont les mêmes
compétences
mais par contre le sénat donc le
bundesrat ne reçoit pas l'ensemble des
autres textes
donc ça allait un autre équilibre donc à
ce moment-là si le sénat devait aller
dans cette direction
me semble-t-il il faudrait selon elle à
réfléchir sur un nouvel équilibre global
c'est ça le point voyez vous on aurait
pu imaginer qu'à l'occasion de la
révision constitutionnelle
ce travail soit fait pour trouver le
nouvel équilibre et c'est ce que le
gouvernement avec sa majorité a essayé
de faire mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
donc en 2008
la gauche s'est exprimé de façon très
claire en disons très simplement je lui
exprime de façon abrupte elle est
opposée à ce que le sénat est un
quelconque moyen de blocage elle s'est
opposée pour dire qu'elle ne souhaite
aucun droit de veto au sénat devant ce
blocage de la gauche la majorité d'alors
devant quand même réunir vous le savez
monsieur le président vous êtes mieux
placés que quiconque n'avait d'autre
choix que d'essayer de retrouver une
majorité permettant de passer non pas
simplement au niveau du parlement mais
de passer ensuite en congrès
c'est la réponse pour laquelle à
l'époque qui n'a pas été possible de
trouver ce nouvel équilibre qui est
indispensable si nous voulons aller dans
cette direction
vous comprenez monsieur le président ma
sensibilité pour cette question qui est
soulevée mais vous comprenez aussi mon
souci d'avoir évidemment un parlement
qui a la possibilité de continuer à
fonctionner de façon équilibrée c'est la
raison pour laquelle mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le gouvernement
salue la jasette sagesse de votre
rapporteur
le bi doyen gélard et de la commission
des lois monsieur le président et vous
propose confronte à leur proposition
d'adopter la motion de renvoi en
commission je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
alors nous allons entamer la discussion
générale
la parole est tout d'abord à madame la
présidente borvo cohen seat pour le
groupe crc spg
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues voilà moi je comprends
et je partage les préoccupations de
notre collègue et de son groupe sur ce
qui s'est passé concernant les
collectivités territoriales mais je le
dis d'emblée je ne partage pas le
contenu de sa proposition et même les
motivations qu'il
qu'il a défendu la réforme des
collectivités locales telle qu'elle a
été adoptée et je parle du fond et de la
forme est significative non pas de
l'incapacité du sénat de pouvoir imposer
son point de vue mais d'un mode de
gouvernement et d'un mode législatif qui
met en cause quand même en grande partie
une vie parlementaire démocratique est
donc tout simplement une vraie
démocratie
le président de la république nous avait
prévenu sa réforme devait absolument
aboutir et devait aboutir dans les
termes qu'il voulait voir y figurer fi
donc de la vie du peuple et des élus
d'ailleurs il n'a pas été consulté le
peuple et les élus non plus et les
nombreuses motions votées par des
assemblées locales comme les critiques
des associations d'élus ont été balayés
en définitive notre assemblée a certes
relier peu ou prou c'est le moins qu'on
pouvait faire ces critiques
ce qui n'a pas eu l'heur de plaire au
président et au gouvernement
les coups de force de ce dernier à
l'assemblée nationale avec l'appui de sa
majorité était autant d'expressions d'un
mépris à l'égard de notre assemblée et
des élus donc ce qui est évidemment
inacceptable
je veux quand même rappeler qu'au bout
du compte la majorité au sénat a accepté
de se déjuger permettant à l'assemblée
nationale de s'en sortir sans avoir à
user de son dernier mot comme nous en
avait menacé le président la république
soyons clairs la majorité sénatoriale a
donné son aval à l'assemblée nationale
et donc donner la primauté à l'assemblée
nationale sur le vote n'aurait rien
changé à la faire puisque le sénat
aurait fait la même chose
ce choix de la solidarité de la majorité
dans les deux chambres et est éminemment
politique d'ailleurs c'est assez logique
mais quand ils n'étaient pas plus
opportunistes ça c'est plus ennuyeux
dans ces conditions la proposition de
loi de nos collègues
notre collègue permettrait-elle de
remédier à ce problème n'ont pas changé
loin d'en être convaincu donc je crois
que c'est une question politique avant
tout et de fonctionnement de nos
institutions qui évidemment fait du
débat parlementaire quand même quelque
chose qui est secondaire
et c'est quand même là la
présidentialisation la majorité
présidentielle en fait tout ça c'est le
fonctionnement global deux institutions
je pense que ça n'a rien à voir
monsieur le président avec aimer ou ne
pas aimer le sénat 1 c'est tout autre
chose donc je pense qu'ils ne seraient
pas légitimes de voter une disposition
qui écorne la primauté une assemblée
élue au suffrage universel direct au
profit d'une deuxième assemblée élue au
suffrage universel indirect ou autrement
dit les élus contre les citoyens c'est
un ce serait un problème je dirai tout
aussi grave
je vais même plus loin contrairement à
nos collègues je pense qu'il faut non
pas rogner sur les pouvoirs de
l'assemblée nationale sur tous les
sujets mais lui donner aux lui redonner
des pouvoirs et une véritable
représentativité de des citoyens
al'inverse de ce qui a cours aujourd'hui
il faut assurer sa primauté par rapport
à l'exécutif et asseoir par conséquence
sa légitimité
l'hyper présidentialisme actuelles
aggravées par la réforme
constitutionnelle en traîne des
pratiques très contestable elle met
aussi le doigt sur l'exigence d'une
démocratisation en profondeur qui décide
de la loi voilà la question
ce ne sont pas les parlementaires qui
décident de l'ordre du jour de la
procédure accélérée du droit d'amender
c'est la majorité parlementaire dans le
cadre existant une relation directe
entre un chef de l'état super puissants
et les députés qui le soutiennent et qui
lui doivent tout dans le cadre d'un
quinquennat au calendrier inversée qui a
été un merci ajoutons les restrictions
au pouvoir de décision budgétaire le
vote bloqué à 6 49 3 et maintenant
l'examen des textes issus des
commissions et le temps de parole contre
ajoutant aussi un mode de scrutin j7
yves un jus s'amenant l'assemblée
nationale à ne pas être représentatifs
du peuple
qu'ils aient un hyperprésident il en
semble pouvoir réduit un fait
majoritaire voilà les problèmes quant au
sénat en 2002 à l'occasion du travail du
groupe de réflexion sur l'institution
sénatoriales mon groupe s'était déjà
opposé à l'accroissement de ses
compétences législatives en général sur
les questions liées aux collectivités
territoriales nous avions considéré qu'
en aucun cas l'esprit et la lettre de la
constitution et au delà la tradition
républicaine n'envisage de donner la
primauté à l'assemblée élue au suffrage
indirect par rapport à l'assemblée élue
au suffrage direct
c'est ce que nous avons réaffirmé à
l'occasion de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2003 loin de
vouloir nier la spécificité du sénat il
nous paraissait plutôt utile de
recentrer le rôle du sénat sur cette
spécificité et c'est avec cet objectif
que nous répondons oui à la question qui
peut se poser de la nécessité d'une
deuxième chambre régime démocratique
d'aucuns la pause nous nous l'avons
posée d'une certaine façon à une époque
nous ne faisons plus de la même façon
mais nous considérons que l'existence de
cette deuxième assemblée se justifie
mais avec un rôle nouveau et spécifiques
nous avons à plusieurs reprises proposé
ici que ce rôle nouveau celui de caisse
de résonance d'initiative des citoyens
et des collectivités locales
nous avons fait ces propositions avec la
conviction que l'institution d'une
démocratie plus participative est la clé
de toute relance de la démocratie en
général elle doit je les dis
s'accompagner d'un renforcement de la
représentation nationale à rebours des
logiques présidentialiste mais la
généralisation l'initiative citoyenne
rendent notre point de vue nécessaire
l'institution d'une interface entre
elles et l'activité parlementaire de
même que la nécessaire démocratie locale
a besoin de l'interface avec le
l'assemblée nationale le sénat a
transformé pourrait assurer cette
mission il pourrait contribuer au
travail démocratique qui manque
aujourd'hui pour assurer le débat sur le
contenu des propositions législatives
dans un aller retour entre les
collectivités locales les citoyens
l'assemblée nationale la véritable
réforme à faire pour
pour nous ce serait d'élargir la
représentativité du sénat et de
renforcer les libertés locales ainsi que
le rôle du parlement voilà qui
mériterait un vrai débat et dans lequel
pourrait s'inscrire les questions sur
qui décide à un moment donné elle ne
saurait passer par une remise en cause
des équilibres institutionnels déjà bien
malmené la question qui demeure posée
bien c'est lui le véritable
démocratisation des institutions de la
république
c'est la raison pour laquelle évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas soutenir la
proposition de loi de nos collègues je
dois dire que nous ne serions pas
hostile à ce qu'une proposition de loi
est compris constitutionnel puisse faire
l'objet d'un grand débat législatif au
sénat puis à l'assemblée nationale
cetera donc c'est vrai que chaque fois
que l'opposition parce que par contre il
ya des propositions de loi venant de la
majorité qui suivent un cursus et qui
aboutissent comme des projets de loi les
propositions de l'opposition elle se
termine toujours par une fin de non
recevoir ou remises à plus tard plus
tard qu'il ne vient en général jamais
sauf si le gouvernement le veut donc
voilà ce qui fait que je dis tout de
suite qu'on est contre cette proposition
le fait de ne pas vouloir qu'il débat
aujourd'hui c'est un autre problème
auquel je crois nous ne pouvons pas ne
pouvons pas accepter
merci la présidente
et bien maintenant nous allons entendre
monsieur françois zocchetto pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
dans monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de nos collègues du
groupe rds est intervenue si je me
rappelle bien dans un contexte
particulier c'était à la veille de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi de réforme des collectivités
territoriales elle a donc été déposée à
un moment très précis très datée et il
est probable même très probable que dans
ce contexte l'existence des dispositions
qui sont aujourd'hui contenues dans
cette proposition de loi qui nous est
soumise aurais-tu une influence certaine
sur le déroulement et probablement sur
l'issue du débat
comme l'a justement rappelé notre
rapporteur président tout à l'heure
l'article 24 de notre constitution
dispose que depuis 1958 le sénat assure
la représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
mais c'est bien plus récemment depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
constitutionnelle du 28 mars 2003 que
notre constitution prévoit que les
projets de loi ayant pour objet
principal l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales sont soumis
en premier lieu au sénat
il est donc tout à fait légitime selon
nous de nous interroger sur cette
question ne faut-il pas aller encore
plus loin que le texte constitutionnel
du 28 mars 2003 et certains dire ou ne
faut-il pas aller jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement
parce qu'on peut avoir l'impression que
on s'est arrêté au milieu du gué et ne
faut-il pas prévoir que le sénat est le
dernier mot pour les textes traitant des
collectivités ou au moins qu'il y ait un
accord parfait entre les deux chambres
sur cette matière alors sur le fond je
dois dire que large majorité des membres
du groupe de l'union centriste sont plus
tu es plutôt favorables à ce changement
car comme je lai indiqué en commission
les collectivités territoriales ont
besoin d'eux
habilité pour fonctionner pour
s'inscrire dans l'histoire de notre pays
elles ont besoin aussi de cette forme de
consensus qui s'exprime par un accord
des deux assemblées
on a vu récemment toute la difficulté
voire même le risque qu'il y avait à
forcer un peu la la manoeuvre et en
utilisant au maximum les contours de
notre de notre constitution que leur
collège sénat représentant constitué
représentant constitutionnel des
collectivités aient le dernier mot ou
participent à un accord parfait apparaît
totalement légitime sur les textes le
concernant est dans la continuité des
dernières évolutions constitutionnel je
crois que là-dessus tous les sénateurs
peuvent être d'accord car il ne s'agit
pas à travers ce débat de remettre en
cause le bicamérisme mais d'aller
jusqu'au bout des prérogatives qui ont
été dévolus à chacune des deux chambres
toutefois et sans vouloir faire sourire
en tant que membre de la commission des
lois
je suis sensible aux arguments qui ont
été énoncées par notre rapporteur
en effet et je pense que le président
colin on conviendra une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle n'est sans doute
pas le meilleur vecteur pour une telle
réforme
on sait bien que cela supposerait que le
texte soit adopté par la voie
référendaire et chacun conviendra cas
référendum n'est certainement pas
pertinent en tout cas et peu pertinent
sur ce thème
en tout cas je ne m'avancerai pas sur
les résultats d'une consultation par
voie référendaire
donc comment arriver à l'objectif c'est
toute la difficulté de l'exercice
et c'est vrai que à titre personnel je
me suis exprimée en commission pour dire
que je comprenais parfaitement le renvoi
du texte en commission le président a
dit que quand on renvoyait en commission
à la commission des lois du sénat
ce n'était pas un enterrement de
première classe et j'en suis quasiment
le garant pour certaines matières que
nous que nous étudions dans cette
commission
mais je vous indique mais sir collègues
qu'une majorité des membres de groupe de
l'union centriste votre contrôleur
renvoi en commission pour les raisons
que j'ai exposé tout à l'heure et en
faveur de l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
ne peut que clarifier et renforcer le
rôle du sénat et les relations que nous
avons avec les élus locaux
je vous remercie de votre attention mais
c'est monsieur zocato maintenant nous
allons entendre notre collègue
jean-pierre michel pour le groupe
socialiste
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le but affiché de la
proposant de loi est très claire et
d'ailleurs son intitulé le traduis
explicitement renforcer la fonction de
représentation par le sénat des
collectivités territoriales de la
république pour les textes qui ont pour
principal objet l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales au sens
deuxième penalty 39 c'est à dire qu'ils
sont soumis en premier lieu au sénat
il s'agit donc de leur appliquer la
procédure prévue pour les lois
organiques relatives au sénat qui devait
être voté dans les mêmes termes par les
deux chambres et pour les propositions
des projets de loi de révision de la
constitution
concrètement il s'agirait donc de donner
au sénat un droit de veto pour les
textes législatifs relatifs à
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales qui sont déposés en
première lecture au sénat
alors d'abord la première question
pourquoi le groupe r d est fait et son
président notre cher collègue collet
propose-t-il cette solution parce qu'il
faut bien le dire la majorité
sénatoriale n'a pas joué son rôle et
qu'elle a gravement failli à ce qui
devait être sa mission en réalité nous
serons peut-être nous serions peut-être
pas là en train de débattre de cette
proposition de loi
6 mesdames et messieurs de la majorité
vous aviez lors de l'examen du projet de
réforme des collectivités territoriales
pleinement rempli la fonction de grand
défenseur des collectivités
territoriales et de ses élus locaux que
vous revendiquez et qui est inscrit dans
la constitution
au lieu de cela que s'est il passé
vous avez renier les travaux de la
mission sénatoriale de l'eau krattinger
qui proposait après une large
concertation une réforme plus
consensuelle des collectivités
territoriales lors des débats portant
sur le projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales cédant à la
volonté élyséenne du moins je le suppose
et gouvernementales j'en suis
certains vous avez après moult
tergiversations et marchandages que l'on
connaît et qui ont été avoué dans les
couloirs et sans crainte vous contredire
vous êtes revenu sur des dispositions
qui avaient adopté ici à une
quasi-unanimité
ainsi par exemple après avoir dans un
premier temps voté contre la suppression
de la clause générale de compétences des
départements et les régions
vous avez fini par accepter la
suppression de celle ci au détriment de
la cohérence et de lys et de la
solidarité des territoires qui les
composent vous l'avez fait contre l'avis
de toutes les associations d'élus les
régions et départements et les communes
sauf l'association créée au dernier
moment par notre collègue aujourd'hui
ministre des collectivités territoriales
mais qui est totalement marginal à mon
avis et le report de l'application de
cette disposition 10 ans d'ailleurs
absolument rien
d'ailleurs vous souvenez tous peut-être
que vous assistez à l'explication de
votre du président gérard longuet
toujours d'ailleurs très bon orateur
comme hier soir qu' il faut relire son
explication de vote
c'est absolument un monument bien sûr
l'assemblée revenus surtout bien sûr un
honneur le sénat mais mais mais mais
nous voterons mais mes chers collègues
votre homme et nous voulons quand même
revenir sur la question dans les plus
brefs délais voilà à peu près ce qu'elle
édition art longue et je dirais on ne
peut plus être plus clair dans un
exercice que je ne veux pas qualifier
par respect pour le président du groupe
ump
de la même manière il est frappant de
voir la majorité sénatoriale a approuvé
la réduction du nombre des élus locaux
entérinant ainsi la défiance de
l'exécutif à l'égard des élus locaux qui
seraient trop nombreux mauvais
gestionnaires paraît-il un paradoxe
un paradoxe pour la chambre qui émanent
justement des élus locaux et qu'ils
étaient lus par eux car c'est quand même
cette suspicion que vous avez exprimé
mes chers collègues
la réduction du nombre des élus locaux
par la création du conseiller
territorial élu hybride à deux têtes
dont on ne sait pas encore le conseil
cautionnait le dira
s'il exerce un mandat ou deux à mon avis
d'un hiver mais on verra n'a pas pour
objectif comme elle a été soutenue de
faire des économies mais beaucoup plus
de réduire l'effectif des élus
départementaux et régionaux
majoritairement de gauche
aujourd'hui ça sera peut-être plus le
cas demain savez en france ça peut
changer mais en tout cas qui privera les
citoyens d'un débat démocratique du fait
de la fusion de ces élections et portera
un coup à la parité et réduire à
l'exception de pluralisme politique
à cet égard d'ailleurs je suggère à
notre estime et et mon estime et
président de la commission des lois de
prévoir une proposition de loi
électorale simple pour dire qu'en 2014
fille le conseiller territorial aura une
voie ou deux dans le collège des élus
sénatoriaux tard aujourd'hui vous êtes
mère et vous avez deux voies vous avez
un super ans est-ce que ce conseiller
territorial pour avoir un suppléant au
titre de conseil général où il siège aux
outils du conseil régional oui c'est
vrai également
ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait qu'il a
mandat ou deux de toute façon la
question se posera alors voilà mes chers
collègues ce que vous avez voulu pour
les collectivités territoriales est donc
aujourd'hui bien entendu nous comprenons
parfaitement que dans ce contexte
et bien nos collègues du raeder ce
toujours très attentif aux pouvoirs du
parlement et notamment du sénat pour les
sénateurs et déposé cette proposition de
loi constitutionnelle
mais cette proposition de loi
elle permet de souligner évidemment la
formidable occasion manquée de faire un
pas un pas supplémentaire vers ne
démocratie décentralisée et elle ne
manque pas d'ambition puisque elle veut
résoudre un problème politique
susceptible de survenir entre
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et de
se reproduire
toutefois renforcé les pouvoirs du sénat
afin qu'ils puissent mieux jouer son
rôle au regard des collectivités
territoriales est elle la solution pour
équilibrer et pallier l'absence de
volonté politique et de cohérence au
sein de la majorité sénatoriale
d'aujourd'hui je ne le pense pas il
serait en effet vingt deux derniers mots
sénat si par ailleurs la majorité de
celui
finit toujours par céder aux desiderata
de l'heure ou de l'autre du gouvernement
ou du président de la république le
sénat n'est pas soumis aux mêmes
contraintes institutionnelles que
l'assemblée nationale il ne peut être
dissous et nonobstant le fait qu'elle a
formés nationale et le dernier mot et
dispose tout de même d'une grande marche
de discussion plus grande d'ailleurs est
plus large que celle de l'assemblée
nationale à lui de convaincre et à lui
et au groupe majoritaire notamment de
faire vivre la navette parlementaire
c'est là à mon avis l'unique moyen de
renforcer la légitimité du sénat et de
faire valoir sa spécificité du à ce
moment électoral c'est-à-dire sa
spécificité le défenseur et que les
tibétains ya d'ailleurs je note que
lorsque le sénat provoc ne vote pas
confondre des textes il aurait pu le
faire pour ce texte et kid smp sont
convoqués par le gouvernement je note
que dans bien des cas et des cas
importants comme la loi pénitentiaire
comme la loi sur la rétention
c'est finalement lé sénat qui a le
dernier mot car le sénat à des solutions
sage relativement consensuel auquel
finalement se rallie au cours de la cmp
est bien les élus de gauche membre de la
cmp aussi bien sénateurs que députés et
le sénat a donc le dernier mot voilà une
façon de faire qui ne bouleverse pas les
équilibres pour notre part bien entendu
nous considérons que le sénat est membre
à part entière du parlement il est élu
au suffrage universel indirect bien sûr
mais il représente le peuple souverain
et il fait preuve d'une universalité
d'intérêt il légifère sur tous les
sujets
les sénateurs sont élus de la nation et
sans contact de l'intérêt général et
aucunement des seuls intérêts des
collectivités territoriales la fonction
du sénat est plus large que celle ci
alors vouloir particulariser la
procédure législative concernant les
textes relative aux collectivités
territoriales présenterait à notre avis
l'inconvénient d'abord de perturber
gravement le fonctionnement des
institutions et l'équilibré qui a été
établi entre amis nathalie le sénat en
particulier le bicamérisme auquel nous
sommes très attachés
et qui consacre la prééminence de la
chambre qui est élu au suffrage
universel direct
l'existence même d'une seconde chambre
dans notre système institutionnel ne
fait plus débat
il en va de même de la nature des
compétences de cette dernière qui doit
conserver sa capacité législatif général
et nous ne voudrions pas qu'un jour le
sénat voit ses compétences comme ça a
été dit dans certains tribune libre voit
ses compétences limiter au seul domaine
des collectivités territoriales et
perdre ainsi sa qualité de législateurs
le pen exercice au même titre que
l'assemblée nationale alors nous
comprenons bien entendu la démarche de
nos collègues du cop rdr veut nous ne
partageons pas sur le fond je crois que
je m'en suis expliqué cette proposition
de loi
mais nous souhaitons d'ailleurs j'ai
montré souligné les conditions dans
lesquelles elle a été présentée dans
lesquelles elle est aujourd'hui discutée
nous sommes favorables à l'ouverture
d'un débat institutionnel bien entendu
qui irait dans le sens avec kelly
brazier pouvoir notamment un
d'élargissement par exemple la base
électorale du sénat mais il n'est pas
question pour nous de donner un droit de
veto supplémentaire au sénat en l'état
cependant je dirais que la technique de
la commission des lois est certainement
des autres commissions de ceux de cette
assemblée et de renvoyer en commission
lorsque on ne sait pas que faire d'une
proposition de loi
alors nous sommes toujours opposés à
cette procédure
donc bien qu'ailleurs étant hostiles au
fond cette proposition de loi
nous nous opposerons au renvoi en
commission afin que le débat puisse
instaurer dans l'hémicycle je vous
remercie mes chers collègues
merci monsieur jean-pierre michel
maintenant notre collègue jean louis
masson pour les non-inscrits
en clôture madame catherine tron la
discussion générale
non monsieur le ministre chers collègues
je comprends tout à fait le fondement de
cette proposition de loi qui nous est
soumise qui nous est proposé et il faut
dire que depuis un an ou deux on a
assisté de la part du gouvernement à des
prises de position des ou disons des
décisions ddd passage en force de
proposition de texte de loi de
différentes différents éléments
concernant les collectivités
territoriales et je dirais le le droit
en général de manière qu'ils étaient
tout à fait déplacée et intolérable
alors je reviendrai pas sur les
charcutage des circonscriptions
législatives dans très peu de temps on
aura le charcutage des des cantons pour
élire les conseillers territoriaux on
aura le charcutage des intercommunalités
bon je trouve que c'est indécent la
pratique gouvernementale est sous
l'autorité du frein de la république est
tout à fait indécente
donc je comprends tout à fait la prise
de position de nos collègues du rdse
sauf qu'ils ont tout à fait raison
ceci étant la solution ne correspond pas
au problème qui est posé le premier
posés çà devrait être respect de la part
du gouvernement de la part de la
majorité d'un minimum de problèmes
d'éthique de comportement correct à
l'égard des collectivités territoriales
de respect de la démocratie locale mais
au niveau de la base est là dessus je
suis tout à fait d'accord par contre
vouloir changer les rapports de force
institutionnel vouloir que finalement le
sénat puisse de plus en plus avoir un
veto dans tous les domaines
ce n'est peut-être pas le meilleur moyen
ni
de faire fonctionner la démocratie ni
d'ailleurs de conforter le rôle du sénat
parce que peut-être à vouloir trop
réagir on peut finir par conduit à par
aboutir à ce que mon bain le sénat la
légitimité du sénat puisse être je
dirais contestée par les uns ou par les
autres
bon moi j'ai été successivement député
du nord fut sénateur
bon je considère quand même que quand on
est député on est l'élu du suffrage
universel direct
alors le suffrage universel indirect est
tout aussi légitime que suffrage
universel direct mais c'est quand même
pas la même chose qu'on est d'accord ou
connaît pas d'accord c'est quand même
pas la même chose à et quand j'étais
député j'ai été élu par cent mille
électeurs ou sens où 80 mille électeurs
canton et sénateurs on n'est nulle part
200 300 300 voix un peu plus quand tout
va bien mais c'est quand même tout à
fait différente
donc moi je ne peux pas m'associer aux
autant je suis alors vraiment pas
d'accord avec la politique du
gouvernement avec l'attitude du crâne la
république avec tout un tas de choses
autant je trouve que des choses qui ont
été faites au cours des deux trois
années sont intolérables scandaleuse et
moi j'en ai par dessus la tête d'un
certain nombre de choses autant là je
crois qu'il faut pas non plus tomber
dans l'excès inverse et je pense que
cette proposition de loi ne va pas à mon
avis obligatoirement dans le sens de la
légitimité de la légitimisation du rôle
du parlement parce qu' il peut y avoir
tiré un effet boomerang
et ce n'est pas opportun donc pour ma
part tout en approuvant tout à fait les
réflexions globales qui ont pu être
faites
je ne voterai pas cette provision de loi
mais c'est maintenant madame trendel
pour le groupe ump
seul président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
après de longues semaines de discussions
et de navettes sur le projet de loi
portant réforme des collectivités
territoriales vous nous soumettez une
seule président colin une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle tendant à écarter
le dernier mot donné à l'assemblée
nationale en cas d'échec de la
commission mixte paritaire
lors de l'examen d'une loi ayant pour
principal objet l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales il est vrai
que notre tentation est grande d'abroger
ces dispositions de l'article 45 de la
constitution
mais quelle erreur ferions nous en
adoptant votre proposition
en effet monsieur le président nous ne
saurions aujourd'hui adopter votre texte
non pas au nom de quelques principes ou
postures ou quelque autre objection
objections politique et pour des raisons
constitutionnelles et républicaine
n'est-il pas parmi nos fonds d'un
pommeau fondements démocratiques et nos
principes républicains
celui de la discussion des textes
législatifs dans les deux chambres
parlementaires
le peuple français a lui-même ratifier
par référendum le 28 septembre 1958 le
principe du dernier mot à l'assemblée
nationale ce principe est celui de
l'article 45 de la constitution
il peut être révisé conformément à
l'article 89 de la constitution à
l'initiative du président de la
république sur proposition du premier
ministre où des membres du parlement
mais les procédures d'y faire et il me
semble important de rappeler en cet
instant ces distinctions
en effet tout projet ou proposition de
révision doit être examiné et voté en
termes identiques par les deux
assemblées
les deux chambres disposent en égal
pouvoir constituant la révision étant
adoptée doit ensuite être ratifiée sapa
référendum soit par décision du
président de la république par une
majorité des trois cinquièmes du congrès
la raison de ces différences de
traitement entre les deux procédures est
évidemment politique le général de
gaulle craignaient que les initiative
parlementaire de révision
et pour objet de détruire son oeuvre
aussi connaissant la réserve de certains
parlementaires à l'égard de la pratique
référendaire il espère et limiter leurs
envies de révision en les soumettant
obligatoirement référendum alors me
direz vous quelles dispositions nous
empêche aujourd'hui d'engager une telle
procédure
sur la forme rien pourtant c'est bien au
renvoi en commission auquel nous invite
le doyen gélard d'autres rapporteur
comme l'a brillamment exposé ce dernier
si nous devions adopter votre
proposition de loi en l'état
c'est alors la procédure référendaire
qui pourrait être lancé en cette
procédure ne serait pas adapté en la
circonstance la question que vous
soulevez aujourd'hui est en réalité
institutionnelle avant d'être politique
l'histoire de la vème république nous
montre d'ailleurs la subtile nuance
toutes les révisions ont été adoptés par
la boîte du congrès sauf celles
concernant le quinquennat en l'an 2000
l'enjeu était alors celui de faire
choisir par le peuple français
la durée du mandat de leurs
représentants la fonction suprême tandis
que les autres révisions
qu'il s'agisse de la nouvelle calédonie
en 1998 de la charte de l'environnement
en 2005 ou du statut pénal du chef de
l'état en 2007 ont trait à
l'organisation même de nos institutions
la pratique observé me direz vous a
conduit à conférer au chef de l'état un
véritable droit de veto en matière de
révision de la constitution alors que
celle ci ne le prévoit pas c'est faux
puisque tout dépend de l'origine de
l'initiative de la révision si elle est
d'origine parlementaire
la révision devra être approuvée par
référendum si elle provient en revanche
du pouvoir exécutif
c'est au président de la république il
appartient de choisir la procédure mais
ne nous égarons égarons pas mes chers
collègues le sujet qui nous préoccupe ce
jour ne porte pas sur la méthode
mais bien sur le fond du sujet traité
pensez-vous raisonnablement que les
français ressentent le besoin de
s'exprimer par voie référendaire sur
l'organisation des travaux des deux
chambres
car sur le soutien le sujet bien celui
là
une guerre de chapelles entre les deux
chambres pour le traitement des sujets
législatives
l'article 45 de la constitution que vous
souhaitez compléter ou plutôt amputer
une partie de la procédure législative
est totalement transparent il est
nécessaire de le lire au regard de
l'article 39 qui précise que les projets
de loi ayant pour principal objet
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales sont soumis en premier
lieu au sénat
c'est bien cet article de la
constitution qui nous intéresse au
premier chef et qui fonde toute notre
légitimité législatives quel besoin
aurions nous de modifier la procédure
existante alors que l'article 24 de la
constitution
sanctuary le statut du sénat en
précisant qu'il assure la représentation
les collectivités territoriales de la
république les français le savent et les
élus ne s'y méprenne pas alors mes chers
collègues nous sortirions nous grandi de
cette haute assemblée
si au moment de légiférer sur l'ensemble
des textes qui nous sont présentés nous
agissions avec le souci permanent du
respect de l'équité territoriale des
élus qui gouvernent les collectivités et
des besoins de nos concitoyens
de surcroît il me semble important que
nous nous fassions mutuellement
confiance députés sénateurs pour réussir
à trouver les termes les plus
appropriées sur chacun des sujets sur
lesquels nous légiférons ensemble pour
toutes ces raisons vous l'aurez compris
mes chers collègues le groupe ump
soutient la demande exprimée par le
rapporteur de renvoyer en commission
cette proposition de loi
alors mes chers collègues notre
président à porter a déposé une motion
tendance on renvoie à la commission du
texte en discussion
la parole est un monsieur jean jacques
hyest président de la commission des
lois pour présenter une motion de renvoi
oui monsieur le président dans la
discussion générale j'ai expliqué les
motifs pour lesquels le renvoi en
commission me paraissent paraissait à la
commission la meilleure formule pour
permettre éventuellement un débat sur
constitutionnelles ultérieures sur
l'équilibré des institutions du
parlement je vous remercie contre la
motion monsieur le président que l'un
vous souhaitez un dernier nom bien alors
il n'ya le gouvernement zones et je me
suis exprimé dans mon intervention
liminaire les propos rester même bien
alors comme il n'ya pas d'explications
de vote je vais consulter sénat sur le
motion de renvoi en commission déposée
par le président les commissions des
lois et je rappelle au cénacle était
alors monsieur le président colin vous
avez demandé 1 souhaiter un public qui
vous est bien sûr accordé de droit mais
j'aimerais savoir si c'est sur le renvoi
en commission ou sur la proposition de
loi en tant que tel c'est sur le renvoi
on y va on y va pour l'on voit mais bien
alors il va être procédé donc au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 ceux qui souhaitent voter
pour me remettre au secrétaire un
bulletin blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter
contre un bulletin bleu et ceux qui
souhaitent se tenir mon rang mais
hamelin rouge le scrutin va être ouvert
dans quelques instants
est ouvert
autun
le scrutin est clos j'invite nos
secrétaires à bien vouloir procéder au
dépouillement
non
e
voici mes chers collègues les résultats
du scrutin 127 sur la motion numéro
intendant renvoi en commission de la
proposition de loi
nombre de votants 338 majorité absolue
du suffrage exprimé pour l'adoption 153
contre 185
le sénat n'a pas adopté
donc je vais maintenant on vous
proposait de passer à l'examen de
l'article unique tel qu'il a été rédigé
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'article
unique constituant l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle et
il y at il des demandes d'explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas et je vais donc mettre
aux voix l'article unique constitue en
lançant la proposition de loi en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public et de droit
il va être procédé aux conditions fixées
par l'article 56 du règlement bis rêviez
d'étape la sainte et je ne vais pas vous
répéter la marche à suivre
secrétaire de se mettre en position
non nous allons recevoir dans quelques
instants
mais tout est politique si j'ai bien
compris
appel que ceux qui souhaitent voté pour
ce texte vont remettre ce côté un
bulletin blanc ce qu'ils vont venir
voter contre un bulletin bleu ce qu'il
souhaite obtenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin est ouvert
ça
ce
encore
le scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à bien vouloir procéder au
dépouillement
je
pendant un enterrement
là
alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 128 sur l'article unique de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
nombre de votants 338 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
222 majorité absolue 112 pour l'adoption
45 contre 177
le sénat n'a pas adopté voilà donc pour
cette proposition wade groupe radical
visant à renforcer la fonction de
représentation des collectivités
territoriales par le sénat tout de suite
preuve par 3 michel grossiord reçoit ce
soir jean pierre bel le président du
groupe socialiste
et bien sûr vous pouvez toujours
retrouver la séance en vod sur notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne